please
[ __ ] tremendous
INRI Fredette comin at you [ __ ]
what's happened you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey let's Friday want to give you
a goodbye kiss
she could have a phenomenal
[ __ ] weekend we had a great
weekend on the podcast from [ __ ] my
main man Jake Ellenberger
we are [ __ ] forget about it we had a
great [ __ ] time I had a great week
but a few shows last night and that's it
tonight I got short the ice house is
sold out tomorrow at its UFC to old
[ __ ] pool I'll be lurking and
that's it next week you got the
[ __ ] but I ball fast and then
after that you got some time but that's
it but Joey what's with the chitter
chatter sparked that [ __ ] we got
a beautiful [ __ ] combination a week
for telling me that little [ __ ]
rascal this [ __ ] is on fire like
Madonna's [ __ ] 84 and then you got
this [ __ ] perennial og full perennial
that's my [ __ ] right there let
that thing hit dry and brittle
my grandma's [ __ ] pubic hairs and I
break it up in this bucket
it's smokes like a [ __ ] tank
look at that nice and [ __ ] smooth
doesn't even climb up the lens you know
how we do people you don't mean though
I'm always in search of the best
[ __ ] reefer whether it's
perennial but it rose it whatever the
[ __ ] it is I'm everywhere if the reef is
good I'm [ __ ] there you understand me
cuz that's what I live for
I don't want to jump up and down I don't
wanna hang out with you [ __ ] on
some [ __ ] stupid Club and VI hell on
donut I just want to smoke pot and see
the devil crack a few jokes hug my
daughter and tell my wife I love that's
it it's that [ __ ] simple that too
much fat ass [ __ ] is that too
much the [ __ ] ask
pilot to Bombardier [ __ ] jump
will Joey's here you know just let you
know it's Friday you gotta look watch
your back watch your back or bigger
weapons on tonight sit facing the
[ __ ] door have your escape route get
ready and knock [ __ ] over you
know he'll be the hand what's going on -
get the [ __ ] out of the way [ __ ]
savage of death you I tell you guys that
lost moment just refined love it listen
the most exciting part of my day is when
I go to the weeks when I got no week
some kids get happier give me the candy
store whatever that's my [ __ ] candy
store smoking weed right hang out with
my cats taking away is too [ __ ] poor
mentally that's why I live for you
understand me trying to pick up
different assets different [ __ ]
things anyone Joey we're gonna give me a
[ __ ] hippie I know I know
Swedish [ __ ] hood guys it just a
potent it just grabbed me by the [ __ ]
temple and spun my head around that's
how goodness waiters they should call
his mother [ __ ] Linda Blair won't
[ __ ] stone for me did you imagine
we'll do a regular civilian a radula a
regular [ __ ]
coffee drinking flip-flop worrying and
civilians just you'll be basically
getting hit by a [ __ ] cannonball this
we like it understand it but that's what
makes me me I'm a [ __ ] nut I love it
I wish you were here with me the smoke
issue go Johanna you could take this I'm
hearing people yell at me I hear people
get hit by cars
it's [ __ ] tremendous but anyway
that's not what we came here for we came
up to wrap my beautiful [ __ ] weekend
I love here we we could be living in
[ __ ] Biafra or some [ __ ] country
or every time we walk by some day they
throw a [ __ ] lit match at us or
something but no way here in the US of a
sleighing big smokin reefer and talked
to my favorite people in the world a
[ __ ] periscope that's how we do
it [ __ ] you understanding my [ __ ]
around if you're walking tonight you
might as well dance
it's Friday [ __ ] put on the [ __ ]
white shoes put on [ __ ] purple rain
polish that [ __ ] helmet and get out
there and show them you're a bad
[ __ ] jack what shut your mouth
I'm talking about shaft
anyway doesn't take a genius to see I'm
[ __ ] storm to the gills here any
minute now stop bustin our [ __ ]
shoulder somewhere over the rainbow
Young's at so I get for that point is
but I get the [ __ ] out of here might say
someone might regret and I should get
[ __ ] up I'm gonna go inside do a
little writing pick up the baby of 5:30
then leaves picking me up with a couple
[ __ ] stars I want to close the week
out of the [ __ ] ice house in other
words he's better than [ __ ] me who
nobody you understand me you know why
cuz I got you guys on my [ __ ] pool
but you guys have my gone I can't
[ __ ] oh is this like steel I feel
like I'm a Coast Guard Ocean's thirteen
I'm sick anyway should we smoke another
bowl or Joey you're too far [ __ ] come
you know me I'll go to a long blows up I
don't give a [ __ ] at this point I'm
walking on ice I'm 53 and I work for the
great want a banana peel if we can't get
high like a family
and we gotta go you gotta go Joey Joey
you gotta go
anyway I love you [ __ ] have a
great weekend we're gonna be back
[ __ ] Monday morning with a podcast
for you nice and [ __ ] early get your
dick hard get you out there [ __ ]
jumping up and down and that's all that
I need to do I'm here to [ __ ] make
you jump up and down so when you go out
there you don't you're a bad
[ __ ] your confidence is on your
chin is up and I'm saying
you walk around come through an air
[ __ ] conference instead of walking
around here in the fair shade off your
shoulders this [ __ ] needs that go relax
breathe I'm saying talk to the police
anyway I love you [ __ ] stay
black and I'm catching the next two days
somewhere or I have a great weekend you
know I love you
Churchill what's happening now and you
without YouTube without the church and
your [ __ ] I have nothing I'd
have nothing okay so stay black have a
good weekend and you know keep you out
of the door right love you